[Music]
in mother-of-pearl news what up what up
how submitted by Leia's awesome hair hmm
lucious a man discovers an old family
heirloom he's actually worth 90 million
dollars Oh some [ __ ] like this my mom
keeps throwing [ __ ] away for no [ __ ]
reason we have no heirlooms dude and you
guys say hoarding is not cool
well this heirloom it's not a party yeah
a family heirloom that's what if the
family heirloom was like that back
scratcher
it was Genghis Khan's yeah this was from
your grandma who had cataracts Filipino
Canadian man so he's had this heirloom
in his family since his grandfather
bought it from a fisherman in the
Philippines in 1959 and will hold it up
with I'm gonna sword it just says it
when you swipe it and they treat it with
respect
when they say it I just saw you pause
your own life okay back into real boot
hanging out board
[Laughter]
just everything has that now as a prefix
so this was a so he thought that this is
just an ornament that resembled a giant
tooth but it turns out it's a 1000 year
old pearl : or something that's [ __ ]
pearl yep that's the [ __ ] Canadian
pulp you know yeah wait why is there
octopus on it so they he had this
octopus commissioned to like hold the
Pearl that's time Howell is that big 90
so how big was the [ __ ] oyster huge
so it's it's from a giant oyster oh like
this big bang clam yeah I've never seen
a clam up I would have sold that [ __ ] at
a garage sale a long time ago it doesn't
even look like anything just like alien
yeah this is ninety million
this is 0.95 eleven pounds and so is he
calling it he's calling a gig of pearl
the gig of pearl this time and I like to
put tiny number yeah you should have
called it put are gonna pour gonna watch
this and be like email do we mail them
right now this baby think about this you
thought Nina pearl what song I know
pearl
yeah yeah so this outweighs the previous
record holder for the world's largest
pearl which was fourteen point one
pounds oh my god by a [ __ ] mile how
did he get it appraised like who oh he
did it
it's the rodeo show Glen's that you went
to Pawn Stars
they're banging appraised right when
they see it
that's how you know anything he says
that you 90 million no yeah so he took
it get the Pearl authenticated of it at
the dirt gem oh oh my god at the
Gemological Institute of America in New
York City but he originally thought it
was a shark tooth
no he just thought it was an ornament
look at [ __ ] Christmas tree ornament
I understand but heirlooms how does a
definition of what it is not get passed
down with I know the label body from the
fishermen and that was it and so that's
why you just thought like oh it's just
been in our family this big-ass thing
that looks like a tooth that looks like
there's something that's very important
to tell somebody that's a [ __ ] pearl
maybe they never knew I know I know I
think a pearl that big that's all a gold
octopus though it's bad I would have
thought that carat gold
Becky she had commissioned like I bet
you Lee his his [ __ ] grandsons gonna
get that and just keep the octopus and
go get rid of that I know cuz he's not
gonna tell the kid what it is either
made more sense if you got a gold
[ __ ] clown it puts before he found
out it was a pearl right fit perfectly
he's like oh [ __ ]
yeah they just say that everywhere we go
why do you continually make one of my
culture because all these missed
opportunities [ __ ] about no pearl that's
90 million dollars that'll change your
life past that family heirloom folk well
he must already be pretty well-off if
he's not thinking about selling that
[ __ ] he'll if he could make a 22 karat
gold ass [ __ ] octopus pretty well off
yeah that's a lot of money dude maybe he
did that after he found out huh yeah but
where'd he come up with the money he's
like chipped a piece off this wood paper
you have to push my closet and just
start up raising [ __ ] how much is this
worth it disapper it disapper yeah in
your backyard
Gold Mouse my dad made for me yeah like
two years ago it's got to be worth
something
it's worth the amount that he paid me to
do for that [ __ ] Mouse
I think Mickey yeah he's you got a gold
mouse now is this big right and it looks
like Mickey Mouse it's like a bootleg
Chinese make you gotta pee I'll take a
pill send it to you guys dude go to the
roadshow bring that [ __ ] imagine I know
a jeweler that could appraise it it he's
spent probably couple g's on that thing
it's probably just how much whatever
gold is on it is the prime material I
need 90 million for it though yeah at
least yeah yeah so they're saying though
that the giggle Perl is impressive he'll
call it by its rightful girl thank you
um but it's still no match for the pearl
of Bordeaux Princesa which is it wait
seventy four point nine [ __ ] it's pretty
close though nothing look like is this
guy
that one's way pretty I think shiny yeah
the other one doesn't look what am i it
looks like a Thanos glove oh yeah it
does it looks like a walnut
I like the poontang yeah but I'm gonna
pose way back there I think it's melting
this one looks like it yeah it happened
in nature it was worth a hundred million
in 2016 it went down huh that was 90
million what it just went down since
we've been talking about this Justin you
know cuz he changed the name the
disappointment of what it was until
advice guys sorry I forgot the privacy
I'm talking about the giant one yeah so
they're saying that he that they have
fishermen who found that found out that
it was worth 100 million 2016 after he
decided to give it to his aunt when he
was about to move to a new house so he
bought took it to the local oh so she
happened to be a local tourism
department chief and so she had it a
pearl appraised and that's when they
found out that it wasn't them so they
did she give it back so now it's being
kept so it still remains a property of
that unnamed fisherman but he lends it
to the local government put it the
museum or whatever at the City Hall I
need to know more fishermen so is that
family gonna sell that or they're like
there's too much emotional I would sell
it so [ __ ] fast immediately I mean
yeah unless it was like a [ __ ] relic
do the prices even fluctuate for keeping
things like that it's just based on
rarity dude I wonder if there's anyone
that's gonna buy it
that's true cuz then the more people
find their shits the lower yours go so
now Nicolas Cage would buy that [ __ ] he
loves [ __ ] like that we're [ __ ]
Leonardo DiCaprio would buy a [ __ ] no he
bites [ __ ] skeleton skulls and stuff
selectively [ __ ] Jake Polaroid do
music [ __ ] museums I donated do they pay
to like hold it like his night they
didn't rent it out
Renta because they they ran out like
[ __ ] I will cut the mildew does like s
190 million but for you
89 million because you are my friend
discount because you are my friend it's
a lie use that business tactic for
everything pressure my friend should I
give you a discount
no I think you're my friend better than
family
imagine that hi stuff like you can
replace it with bubblegum and I'll not
even know how big is it is giant water
bottle public oh that's that's like his
pourcel right there that is big that is
a [ __ ] huge pearl deep big-ass car
but then the head picks it up it's like
tiny yeah woman I said it yeah why did
he choose a octopus you dumbass
discipline solid gold or like plated 22
karat like fake like it's cool dude it's
22 karat how many pounds is the octopus
no no no the pearl is 60 so the octopus
needs to be heavy enough to hold 60
pounds up but then if this 22 is it -
isn't it too soft
yeah I'd have to be plated at that point
cuz they might be too sorrow because
gold as a material yeah yeah it's 22
karat pretty pure yeah interested
because that's a lot of money to just
the just that octopus alone could be
like just [ __ ] supporter million or
something different yeah them yeah I
know just come up with a different one
so lucky dude ninety million dollars we
don't know enough fishermen
[Music]
[Music]